the Joe Rogan experience sometimes I
watch these replays 10-15 times from
different angles and all of a sudden L
see something and it's like a light bulb
moment I love those moments but yeah
Anderson had many of those moments in
his career where you recognized that he
had seen a pattern and then he just
struck on that pattern and hit paydirt
and he like Jesus Christ yeah so max
Holloway does it now that first round
he's like he's down load round yeah I
know he gathers he gathers information
he studies their patterns and that's why
if you look at max Holloway stats he's
first round he's percentage of success
he's loved and his output slowed but
then as his success rate increases so
does his output he's ridiculous like I
don't know any other fighter that does
that
no he's brilliant in that in his output
is preposterous Zao pit is just so
outrageous but not as outrageous as
colby Covington's colby covington recipe
might have the most outrageous output in
the sport
yes outrageous what about him in the
Eastman line hitting balls outrageous so
it's all who's the better wrestler yes
who's the better wrestler and who has
more power and who can keep that up for
the longest because Colby can keep that
[ __ ] up for five rounds he's done an
amazing job of getting people to dismiss
him because they think he's a piece of
[ __ ] with his maggot and all the trash
that he does it's [ __ ] brilliant man
because what he's done is just insult
everybody and anybody get a lot of
people talking about him and then [ __ ]
people up so it's like whoa this is a
crazy combination because it [ __ ] with
their head they don't want to lose to
this guy they don't want to hear him
talk [ __ ] after he beats your ass he's
gonna still talk [ __ ] and [ __ ] there's a
slight I don't know depending upon the
person but it at least slight burden and
experiencing that from a person it might
be a big burden maybe you're one of
those people that has a hard time
getting [ __ ] with and you can't just
keeps you up at night and then it's like
oh maybe maybe it diminishes your
performance 20% maybe 30% yeah and Colby
doesn't get tired he keeps coming it's
terrifying
Robbie Laura just kept bobbing and
weaving and hoping for these openings
that were never there uh-huh did you
call me just on you he was punching some
ridiculous amount like
every 2.4 seconds or some crazy [ __ ] he
broke the work rate right yeah yeah
something like that
against Robbie Lawler no but Robbie just
you know he it like that first round in
particular when he's up against the
fence and he wasn't even hand fight in
the chokes like that it looked like he
was kind of coasting for a couple of
rounds with the intention of getting
started later hmm but then I just I just
think the the intensity of Kobe just
burned him out faster than he expected I
think when you're an explosive guy like
Robbie is where he fires [ __ ]
hurricane speed bombs at you just and
when he does that he's going 100% 100%
colby never goes on a % if you watch him
he's punching like 70% 60% 70% 60% and
he just stays on you stays on you very
Nick Diaz like India's his early days
like when Diaz fought Frank Shamrock
perfect example like just puts that pace
on you keeps talking [ __ ] and puts that
pace on you and he's hitting you a lot
so you're always tight look you're
always tightening up tightening up and
it's just draining your battery yeah and
you don't want to lose to this guy cuz
he's talked so much [ __ ] and you're like
well he's talked so much [ __ ] when I get
ahold of them and guess what when you
get ahold of him he's great that's the
problem the problem is all those things
that [ __ ] with you plus he's a great
fighter
so the meanness the [ __ ] talking all the
the magus tough the strippers the cringe
you're like oh my god right and then on
top of it the [ __ ] output inside the
Octagon you're like [ __ ] he's doing all
that and he's [ __ ] me up he might
have [ __ ] me up even if he didn't do
all that but he does all that and I
don't want to lose to him and he's
[ __ ] me up it's like goddamn do you
think there's a point where Kobe thinks
you know any point during his training
camp like chef stack the odds against
myself here I at that moment before
Marcus Davis where I thought to myself
if I lose here I'm gonna like it I'm
gonna look really [ __ ] stupid I think
that Kobe is doing a brilliant job of
playing a bad guy like pro wrestling
style and I think he didn't used to do
that early in his career he was a
hard-working guy who just went out there
and fought his ass off but people didn't
give a [ __ ] and they weren't giving him
the credit that he deserves and so he
turned heel
and from that he's become the interim
welterweight champion he's one of the
most talked-about guys in the sport he
took on a character that's what I think
and I think that character is super
successful it [ __ ] with people you
know I mean and he can [ __ ] fight man
yeah you can't underestimate that that
kind of car do the cardio is crazy
to be able do that for five rounds
that's bananas that that pace is insane
yeah I'm Robbie loyalist I'm strong as
well he's such a difficult person to
hold down I wonder whether I wonder
whether Robbie Lawler left some of his
training camp you know whether he left
some of his effort in the gym I would
imagine Robbie Lowell is the kind of guy
that still trains like he's in his 20s
like he's like on it every day
well maybe or maybe they train together
and when they trained together Coby was
getting the best of it I mean I think
they did train together at American Top
Team you know maybe Colby knew that he
get out wrestle him he knew he just
stayed on him he would break him and out
wrestle him I mean when someone has an
arresting advantage it goes back to this
one more time someone has a wrestling
advantage that is a big deal when you
start getting tired and this guy has
better technique than you and he's not
as tired as you are because he's
fighting more efficiently and then he
gets ahold of you and then [ __ ] him on
my back and then you like goddammit and
then you try to get back up but you
can't and the bells over and you get
back up new guard got to keep this guy
from taking me down then boom he takes
you down to death again he keeps
punching you on the feet it keeps
hitting you and making you move
backwards and you just look at Al and
this big bomb but there's never an
opening for it you think he's gonna slow
down but he never does so Colby against
could be but a catch wait what do you
reckon
who outpaces the other one dude they
could get Ted Nugent to sing enough [ __ ]
yeah I think that's an amazing fight if
the khabib ever did want to fight at 170
I think him versus Usman were also being
amazing frightening I want to see Colby
a new spawn I mean that's the fight
right I mean and I also think if you're
going to have an interim champion you
should treat that fighter like it's a
champion like you can't just take their
fight
you can't take their belt away if they
don't want to fight right now because
they're injured or because they need
surgery I think we have to respect the
championship title otherwise people are
going to look at interim championships
like it doesn't mean anything it should
mean as much as a championship like
we're saying you have to fight for the
title next so to say that they don't
have to fight for the title next and
we're just gonna take that thing away
from you you just take it away like but
you still fight the person still fight
it so there's still the champion they
didn't lose you just take it away
because what is there a mandatory
contender that the WBA the WBC the IBF
no it's just the UFC the FC decides like
who fights and who fights when I'm happy
that they have interim interim
championships because I think there's
times and places for that but you got to
treat it like it's a championship and
Kobe never lost the championship yeah he
won that interim title against RDA and
incredible performance and then they
just take it away from
[Applause]